foreign
[Music]
with this but the idea is that we you
know sit down with
people hopefully where it's a rational
discussion
all right
Peter yeah Jesus you ready for this yep
sure am because when I pull this lever
it's gonna start the Rapture and all the
true Christians are going to come from
Earth and land here in the kingdom of
God yep
do you want to do this together do this
as a team count down yeah I mean
whatever you want to do let's count down
for five ready like five five
four three two one rapture
Hey where's everybody
yeah uh Jesus this is kind of what I was
worried about everybody on Earth is a
pretty bad sinner everybody I mean
surely somebody's worthy of the Kingdom
of Heaven though
not really I mean really between the
hatred violence and bad stand-up
specials there's nobody down I mean
internet porn itself makes it so 99 of
humans can't get up here I I really have
you seen what they wrote about you on
Twitter I have an account but I don't
ever check it I I wouldn't check it it's
just not going to be good for your
self-esteem I just think uh I just think
we're gonna have to lower the bar quite
a bit if you want to get people into the
club if you know what I mean the bar is
pretty low as it is I mean I'm a
forgiving kind of guy you know the
crucifixion I was up there for getting
everybody's sins and stuff they're
supposed to show up right now yeah no
you bring it up uh I know um but I I
just don't think it oh oh spoke too soon
someone's coming
foreign
I'm not here
Kurt
go back down
that punch is not for you
you didn't ask that stealing you can't
come in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I don't know if we can find a you know
like a split the difference between
scalding hot ruin my mouth and something
Joe Lewis would leave in a fire hydrant
because that is tepid and disgusting
that's a horrible start to my day uh we
have a lot to discuss today by the way I
don't know if you notice North Korea
they've been launching some fireworks
we'll talk about that uh Cory Booker is
straight
we'll talk about that
it's fact check liar
right away Snopes like wait uh okay yeah
no him and Magic Johnson they uh they
have like the straight man's version of
the Rotary Club yeah and uh we'll be
talking about uh the refugee crisis uh
which uh you know is not really a crisis
uh and a lot of people are accusing the
United States of being racist and only
caring about Ukrainian refugees it's a
lot let me just give you give you the
short end of it okay the short end of it
is this we've taken in more refugees who
are not white over the last few years
countries that have taken in the most uh
amount of Ukrainian refugees namely like
Poland and Hungary have been excoriated
uh also the reason that Americans are
more sympathetic is because these are
women and children as opposed to
military aged fighting men leaving Syria
uh and bringing their Kalashnikov so
that's just a recap uh before we move on
to anything else
YouTube and I'm going to tell you this
we have no idea how long you guys can
comment below two questions over under
on how long this show stays up when I
introduce who we have here in the studio
today I don't know what over under means
I understand it's a betting term correct
and would you rather date a Syrian
refugee or Ukrainian Refugee comment
below men women z's are all welcome
Gerald I don't have time for you today
because we have two other people here we
have of course Landau Dave Ahoy is here
and uh Nick depalo is in studio in uh
third slash fourths hello how are you
I'm doing well how are you great great
to be here what are you doing you're
doing a character
what are you the the ventrillex I'm
Corey Booker's ego
lip whatever and every time Rosario
Dawson leans in for a kiss you have to
go
were they dating or something huh yeah I
think well she's covering allegedly
right Snopes right I thought she was
dating Gerald Nadler
no she was dating a Jerry Nadler ah
common misconception yeah no I I don't
uh of course no look he's straight As
narrow Cory Booker and um Nick you're
going to be uh this weekend uh you're
doing hyenas hyenas uh Friday night in
Dallas uh two shows and then Saturday
night in Fort Worth I didn't know there
was a difference but boom there is yeah
they got a thing about that how far is
uh are they apart the clubs I don't know
how far apart they are but I was just
you know because I'm walking by the way
yeah yeah yeah well that's always be
sure to uh it's a nice uh nice stroll
down south Dallas yeah yeah yeah you
can't miss that scene and if you can
make it out to Denton uh UNT where we
did the change of my mind it's the uh
it's the Harvard of Denton County yes
it's great it's the what it's the harbor
to Vinton County very nice Harvard yeah
well let's see he's not aware of he's
not an academic type you can also excuse
me I'm not an academic type I want the
universe to make 2.4 business
administration that's pretty good like I
said I'm not the academic well then you
should know that UNT is the Harvard of
Denton all right let's let's hear how
you're talking about Texas who cares I'm
not talking about Texas I'm talking
about exclusively Denton it is the
Harvard of Denton County the home is
Denton well that's the usually the
follow-up question and that's why it's
the Harvard of Denton it's in Denton yes
it's Denton is in what state this does
not include Collin County it does not
include the surrounding counties Texas I
I think yes it's Denton County Texas
right it's Texas who cares go ahead it's
the Harvard of Denton County they
deserve the respect a lot of people
sending their kids to Texas for a good
education that didn't well apparently
from the southern border now what is
that a lot of them sending their sons to
UT to set women's freestyle swim meet
records yeah it's usually so it's
usually over a fact but not really for
college their mascot's gonna change from
a longhorn to just long you know
I'm gonna transfer a portal yes nose
guard at Nebraska and uh Dave you're
going to be in Wisconsin uh April 30th
yes uh Green Bay the Meyer okay so we
have a lot to get to like I said it goes
off the rails here quickly but we love
having everyone uh first up lizzo oh has
a new show did you know this she has a
new show a new series you big lizzo fan
there Nick I know more about Denton
yeah I know lizzo has a nice little
heart-shaped ass well that's what
happens when lizzo sits on the hood of a
car so
did you head
so uh lizzo's new series big girls with
multiple R's let's take a look
watch out for the big girl one generally
does
are these her friends I think so is that
all her no that's not what was that
casting call oh that's Margaret Chuck
she looks horrible just watch out she's
gonna do her mom's voice
oh everyone is this a teaser is this
what is this this is just okay so that's
like a jumbo highlighter it looks like
the Cowboys starting lineup yes
Moesha has gained some weight since the
90s oh Asia likes a continent they can
still move it
ariani doubles rounding
yeah Count Me In
[Laughter]
what a coronary you notice how those
girls were big but just not quite as big
as lizzo is that like the hot girl thing
where they hang out with other girls
that are not quite as attractive yes it
could be like yeah exactly she's like
y'all are not quite as fat right she did
have the Chris Farley working for the
weekend yeah exactly yeah you got to
give him that only there was no Shwayze
no that one girl that did the splits
couldn't get up by the way they had to
roll back yeah and then they had to come
out with a blow torch and eat up the
like get your tongue stuck to a frozen
Point yeah it was just a mopped floor
and they were like oh no oh
Pine salt goodness
it's like to warm them up you know they
have those massage guns with them they
had to use one of those belt Sanders
I gotta do splits [ __ ] get the belt
sander
the war or the male or walking power
tool
at least it told us what the show is
about yes yeah it's dropping tomorrow
yeah just like most what's it about
cholesterol yes it's exactly and
diabetes feet yeah really about side
effects
I thought I saw a BB King in there
the ghost of Wilford Brimley is just
cashing in
one's just playing Lucille at the end
yeah well it's also probably Tom Selleck
probably a few reverse mortgages oh for
sure so and some mesothelioma you know
because they got the uh got the Cobalt
slash asbestos hip replacement a couple
rational scooters to go around
you'd need a few a tub with a door on it
yes legless shopping
but at least they make it to the Grand
Canyon okay
so uh I don't know what you're saying
that's not nice look it's called big
girls and it's celebrating uh uh dying
slowly yeah
so I don't know that yet no we don't
know that yet just wait I'm sorry for a
year it must be so hard are there any
doctors out there Physicians can you
comment but comment below if you're on
YouTube doctors Physicians because we
have to change my mind coming up Monday
and one guy was even saying you know
transgender people being uh
discriminated against by all and I even
said like doctors he goes yeah doctors I
mean what is a doctor going to do you
can't hey what's your uh what's your uh
uh uh you know what okay height and
weight hey you know what let's just
leave this blank and uh give you an
a-okay how do you do it you well it's
isn't it illegal
it's not illegal but they're trying to
make it so first of all there's four of
them on the planet so it's really not an
issue but right there are four planets
yeah there's one Trans on each planet
yes
the point is uh something about the moon
and the tides gravitational pull I don't
know but lizzo just caused uh she fast
forwarded a hundred years of climate
change thanks for that thanks for that
take it up with her so now let's move on
to uh someone else who is a very
respectable though uh Ken uh sorry Ken
katanji Brown Jackson oh you had it
right yeah yes Kenneth Jackson
um
well more important that Cory Booker had
his turn to grill the Supreme Court
nominee okay so we talked yesterday
yesterday about how this uh Supreme
Court nominee you know has been uh made
it her or his own diet to lessen
sentences for child pornographers uh but
Cory Booker wanted to make sure that he
got his shots in and uh like he did with
Kavanaugh yeah yeah I remember his
Spartacus moment yeah
except instead of saying I'm Spartacus
everyone just moved one seat away and
said I'm not with him
and he did not hold back here he is
laying into the potential Justice and
the most important court in the land as
Langston hugheslet wrote oh let America
be America again
the land that never has been yet but yet
must be the land where everyone is free
oh yes I say it plain America never was
America to me but I swear this oath
America will be and how much wood would
a woodchuck chuck that is the story of
how you got to this desk and so you
faced insults here that were shocking to
me well actually not shocking
but you are here because of that kind of
love
and nobody's taken this away from me
don't worry
she's disgusting God has got you on the
left and how do I know that because
you're here yeah and I know what it's
taken for you to sit in that seat you
got here how every black woman in
America who's gotten anywhere adopted by
white parents by being like
Ginger Roger said
I did everything Fred Astaire did but
backwards in heels then he said Fred
Astaire and and so I I'm just sitting
here saying nobody's stealing my joy
nobody's gonna make me angry
I'll be someone with extraordinary
qualifications character experience and
integrity details and that person will
be the first black woman ever nominated
to the United States Supreme Court okay
well here's it's just like affirmative
action let's say that uh katanji Brown
Miss Jackson Miss Jackson
let's say that this person becomes uh
because I don't want to say uh you know
man or woman because she can't Define it
so I wouldn't want a dead name no no no
you Miss Jackson yeah um becomes a
Supreme Court Justice it's like
affirmative action she can never know if
it's because she was qualified
that's the issue here you you rob people
of their win she can never know if she
was the right person for the job because
former Vice President Joe Biden said it
will be a black woman well that
eliminates a good portion of good
portion of the pool of talent
is there are you saying there was nobody
else qualified how about you just go
with qualified and if it turns out to be
her I am all for it well the problem is
if you're qualified they accuse you of
being a gang rapist well that's yeah
that's true what is this but it wouldn't
but
I remember him with with Kavanaugh oh
yeah oh yeah the just the grand stand he
just made that all about he just said he
did a little five-man you know one-act
show one-man play yes for himself she
was even getting irritated hey this is
my moment [ __ ] yes exactly that's the
look she had on her face yeah such a oh
he's a tool he never misses an
opportunity to grandstand and he screwed
up Newark so bad that he decided to go
to Congress yeah exactly I don't
understand he robbed that city of
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in funding for Education just
completely wasted it on corporate people
coming in and advising from New York
ransacked the city and then was like I
think I'll run for uh Congress yeah
that's a good idea Gerald the correct
term is jacked he jacked the city the
city yes yes
guy that would let him yes
unbelievable but I got you mean you take
some serious woman yes yes yeah every
woman yes every woman yeah who he likes
very very much yes loves him can't get
enough of the ladies no yeah sure here's
also uh Kevin Booker providing an
anecdote uh which 100 percent act you
can take this to the bank actually
happened we appreciate something that we
get
we don't I know Tim Scott does
when I first came to this place I was
the fourth black person ever popularly
elected to the United States Senate and
I still remember fourth an
accomplishment a lot of mixed people
white folks black folks work here but at
night when people are online to come in
to clean this place they're a fortune
the percentage of minorities shift a lot
and so I'm walking here first week I'm
here comes here comes the line it's been
here for decades doing the
Urgent work of the Senate but it's the
unglamorous work that goes on no matter
who's in the offices the guy comes up to
me all he wants to say I can tell is I'm
so happy you're here but he comes up and
he can't get the words out and this man
my Elder starts crying not a joke
and I I just hugged him and he just kept
telling me it is so good to see you here
it's so good to see you here and we
couldn't stop kissing turns out we were
elated he was like half brother right
can you give me some money rolling her
tongue around in her mouth yeah like
Nancy Pelosi she's sucking on her
denture yeah
what an idiot that oh my God he came and
I knew what he wanted to say to me but
he couldn't get the words out yeah no
I was the fourth what is it what point
do you say I was the 19th
Junior senator who was biracial damn it
I mean we're just like okay you're a
fourth black guy who was elected in this
just stop we get it they cannot they
just can't stop themselves from wedging
it in there he's the well Stephen
they're natural entertainers yes
and jumpers
I'm just trying to say the most racist
yes they're the the natural tests yes
they're very uh they're a very oratory
culture just Jimmy the Greek talking
about yes you see what it is this is
just like it when when leftist said his
make up ridiculous stories about their
kids that's what it is yeah yeah like
yeah my three-year-old said to me mom
every every time we use plastic straws
the whales cry for the planets yes it
totally happens every time the Dolphins
keep getting caught in the tuna Nets
yeah no thank you two-year-old found
tweets that you read where you're like
can you talk your kid hangs himself at
five yeah with a six-pack uh plastic
they use a Tweed rope yeah right yeah
because you took away his toy yeah
upstairs hanging himself with a Slinky
Dog [ __ ] away it's sickle and Hammer
Cory Booker because he finds his
goldfish caught a little six-pack wire
just taking himself out yeah
he never misses an opportunity to make
about him himself though right his pet
turtle is just making his way to the
Plastics draw pack
I think he went into Mr Bojangles at the
end
missed about Jenkins the funniest thing
about Sammy Davis Jr yes I thought you
were too young to know that the drivers
they're not dying it's just how he got
lost that's how he lost the eye sorry
but the the people who don't we've
talked about I don't know this I don't
think you don't know this uh I I heard
it was a spitball go ahead from Dean
Martin
it was just Frank's spinning oh my gosh
I got you do you know how he lost his
eye
car accident so it's a car accident but
it's worse than that back then Cadillacs
the horn had a protruding sharp 3D
ornament you're kidding so he crashed
you're kidding me yeah that's the best
story I've ever heard yeah yeah that's
how he lost his eye yeah most people
think it's from Frank hitting him from
not shining his shoes correctly
oh that was the lip that was the lip
oh man that was a good one
let's make these horns sharper than they
were before that's so funny yeah they're
looking at it way before airbags they're
like what do we need I don't know
protruding glass yeah that was a true
Ray Charles borrowed that car like a
week later that's when they came up with
the Double Glass yeah it's got to get
both of them boy this this glass really
should be tempered yeah yeah thanks
information I could have used yesterday
babe so Cadillac blinded
they don't use that in their ads still
come on man it's the best car out there
yeah they could have at least had Mr
spokesperson yeah the guy died 30
million in debt
he couldn't see the cars very well you
get a true story my father-in-law saw
Ray Charles at the airport hand to God
was reading a Playboy in Braille that's
a true story how that happened God
one-handed hmm
I like them kitties yes yes is it a
topographical turn-offs
smokers yes
arrogant men blind guys
but every time oh them boobs feel good
steering wheel horns that are Sharp
chain link glove department
so uh she's like old baby seats yeah
they're just meat hooks yes exactly like
it was the baby in the middle yeah
that's all they were in like the 1950s
yeah
umbrella handles yeah and if you're
honoring iron and if you were in the
front seat you were lucky enough to get
someone's arm yeah the best yeah yeah
stop short but if they decided to just
grip the wheel it was like well we got
to get a new kid Sammy Take the Wheel
you're gonna lose an eye
so all right North Korea let's move on
to this anything more on Cory Booker no
I think we've done our job uh North
Korea going to international news here
uh
uh well I guess it's a segue insane
people
insane people with closeted urges
Kim Jong-un test fired a new
intercontinental ballistic missile uh uh
today
yeah yeah Kim's style is unmatched yeah
we showed up he showed up in a Tom
Cruise jacket from Top Gun really yeah
yeah he did but uses the uses the collar
as a bib like the fur and everything
he looks like Andrew rice clay
[Laughter]
hey throw that picture up there again
yeah throw that picture that picture up
there Kim Jong-un throw it out I gotta I
gotta find one oh you didn't see it I
haven't either Oh I thought we had the
picture with him in the James Dean
jacket yeah yeah he's got his everywhere
where's his little James Dean jacket Kim
Jong-un yeah he's got his little it
looks like right before Lefty gets
whacked at the end of Donnie Brosco and
he just that's how he dresses now before
he like I think he got all of Pacino's
stuff from that movie because all the
jewelry yeah right before he goes does
he take the jewelry no he leaves it off
he leaves the jewels he's good at home
oh he was generous
yeah he's no he's not coming I do that
every time I do a gig with my wife well
that's what Al Pacino does now every
time he does a donut cake on Detroit
here is my wallet
I feel that way every time Al Pacino
appears on camera right now when I was
watching the uh not the part of the
Irishman yes I'm sitting there like wait
is he supposed to be Jimmy Hoffa Jimmy
Hoff has Midwest she's like I'm Jimmy
Hoffa here
all right here it is
oh my God
it's a gay Fonzie yes
yes like an Asian
coming back up there instead of hitting
a jukebox he hits a public stall hey
nobody here so this is the first
InterContinental uh I'm just gonna say
ICBM from here and out uh ICBM testing
set November of I think it's 2017. it's
been a while and uh that was of course
before the Singapore Summit with Trump
and uh uh the missile went higher longer
than the 2017 and that one was called
Hua song which I know I had to look it
up to make sure I had it right I thought
it was a phone company
um and that showed that it could hit the
United States oh that's good yeah that's
exactly what we need is a much more
capable North Korea aligning with you
know yeah exactly Russia other people
that don't like us that's that's
fantastic I love it when those things
fall in the water that's right that's
what I like yeah when they actually can
fly well hopefully we can stop it
through the you know the missile defense
system that everyone mocked that Ronald
Reagan you know uh helped starhead which
end up ended up becoming the actual you
know basis for all of Israel's defense
their Iron Dome yeah
otherwise known as Cory Booker good
night everybody
that's the iron rod
oh
spare the Rose's nickname at the bath
house yes Sausalito and by nickname we
just mean pet name from fauci no one
else called him that it was an exclusive
what happened to that little girl oh
we're gonna get into fouches he's going
to retire soon so is Booker is what a
bowler yes that's actually I should let
you guys know seven plus one things that
fouchie's going to do next yeah we have
that we have another seven plus one in a
while so hey by the way Kim Jong-un
missile now capable of hitting the
United States longer further than ever
more powerful everyone former Vice
President Joe Biden uh said this a
little over a year ago America is back I
speak today as president of the United
States at the very start of my
Administration and I'm sending a clear
message to the world America is back
that's like a Backstreet Boys song it's
always a comeback it's like guess who's
back what I thought I never knew you
left now hey everybody again and we're
here to stay this time and where did you
go
exactly that's what I I never understood
did anybody even Democrats by the way
back from what a perfect economy yeah
exactly yeah we have respect all over
the world will be built up by Miller
back back from wine got people to start
spending their own fair share in NATO
yes we're about to sucking up to
countries we don't like in the first
place build back better it sounds like a
slogan at Home Depot on the Labor Day
yeah
only it'd be pronounced in Spanish yeah
it's just which is I believe a
bildobacko better that's how I think it
absolutely how I think it goes not true
so let's let's go through it though he
meant this internationally how back is
America on the world stage okay away the
Afghanistan withdrawal we still don't
know how many Americans have been left
there of course you had Russian Lady uh
Ukraine you have Iran now producing
enriched uranium of course we've
emboldened China and we're standing with
them now we have North Korea testing the
intercontinental ballistic missiles more
effectively than ever before and
something that I find really funny uh
rather than getting oil from ourselves
uh we're begging Venezuela so we're
we're here's the funny thing is they
haven't made up their mind
not sure yet yeah former Vice President
Joe Biden is like hey evil dictator
Maduro could you give us oil like I
don't know oh Stephen you're playing
cherry picking points yes no he just
lifts it off 55. that's what it said
there's one cherries we have pipelines
here it doesn't matter Saudi Arabia is
not taking our calls anyway but they
took calls from Putin so yeah we're
definitely back yeah we love when
exactly don't take our calls yeah we're
fine yeah we're good I'm not a big Saudi
Arabia fan the only way I would call
Saudi Arabia is if I had like Donald
Duck and Chippendale or when I call but
I push a button they pick up the phone
and the dynamite explodes on the other
end of the receiver but somehow goes
through like
I have the first president to [ __ ] his
pants at the Vatican yep yep good for
him even God hates him even the Lord is
like a lot of Cub Scouts have but not a
presence yes
Nick come on don't don't steal their
accomplishment yeah it's the it's the
Vatican poop it's the Vatican yeah it's
right next to your [ __ ] bracelet hey by
the way
light a candle for your anus yeah that's
what it is is that When the Smoke comes
out of the Vatican they're trying to get
the smell out of the house
sponsorship just turns out they needed
it
lifetime supply it was brussels sprouts
Brussels sprout knighted yeah
like holy water there
uh yeah but what about uh that got
Cardinal with the beach house they were
having asparagus so that was also yeah
oh okay but all over the world please
lactose intolerance Cardinal beach house
yes uh what about the rest of all of the
Cardinals we're having asparagus and
Brussels all of them that's what
happened it's a problem we've been
telling them they need to bury their
diet hey lionesscrata.com uh tour Dave
and I are going to be in Tulsa yeah the
Tulsa Ballroom May 14th June 18th we
added a show uh to uh Pikes Peak Center
in Colorado Springs so May and June we
had to add a show because it sold out
thank you guys and uh all right let's
move on to uh fauci you asked about it
we have to
fine why do you got to ruin every show
that we do I why do you have to do that
try hard you know we're sitting here
takes effort Stephen
I mean you have to find new ways I think
he's Ned Flanders I yelled at him on the
phone last week and then the power went
out on my Late Show
anything I got somebody with my back
yeah I think I think he's got he's that
Godly yeah I don't know if you can I
don't know if skinamax counts as your
late show
it does to me
it does to me every Hotel I called you
guys got skidamax what no Dave stop
nothing here we do have guest Wi-Fi yeah
but do you have skin
all right home yes
can I come over paying your basic cable
it waiting patiently for your your soft
core to come on at 1am yeah
hold on but if there's a Shannon Tweed
at 2 30. I think there's a special in
the Duke lacrosse team thing oh it's
great oh all right hey Amy let's move on
speaking of steamy bath houses fouchy
there's some Segways uh for a moment
here we have an audio clip from a recent
show where fauci said that he might and
oh my God I really uh hope this is true
but of course I I don't think so because
I wish I loved anything as much as fauci
just loves being in front of the camera
and or microphone but he did say he
might consider a career change is
retirement or stepping back into a
consultant role and eat like that are
you considering those options Brad I
certainly am because I've got to do it
sometime I can't I can't stay at this
job forever unless my staff is going to
find me slumped over my desk
not do that what would you do if you
were tight like are you a pickleball guy
is there like some bowling career I
don't know about there's something
you're looking to do no I I
unfortunately am somewhat of a
uni-dimensional physician scientist
Public Health person right you haven't
been a physician for 40 years what he
should try virology yes yeah go into it
try to try dabble in that how he
replicates and stop it did he just say
I'm uni-dimensional and list off three
things that he does yeah that's a good
point that's a good point try saving
people we've been listening to this guy
I am unidimensional here's five things
yeah follow follow the science fiction
yeah that word works it's L Ron fauci
it's going to test your theme levels
which now brings us to this week's seven
plus one seven plus one things fauci
wants to do next
foreign
in the chamber
all right so this is seven plus one it
could be career choices but also it's
really just things that he wants to do
next they aren't necessarily careers but
they could be uh so Dave let's have you
uh let's have you go number seven uh
seven plus one thinks fauci wants to do
next oh set the women's NCAA 500 meter
swim record oh well that would be yeah
because he can do that now it's easy to
do number six things that fauci would
like to do next uh stuff himself in a
locker of his own volition
so that would be it
that'd be nice for a change yeah he
wants to you know sort of like
reappropriating it yeah yeah you know
uh now hey how about Let's uh Nick
what's number five uh top things that
fauci wants to do next lesbian softball
pitcher
honestly throw like a [ __ ] you know
what's so funny about did you watch the
documentary of course you didn't you
shouldn't have he had that laminated
what does he mean yeah the documentary
on fauci on Disney I directed it what do
you mean she directed oh my God uh no I
didn't on Disney yeah it's on Disney
plus Disney can you play a fairy yes
well they replaced the rock with him in
the tooth fairy four he's the enforcer
of the lower hockey leagues did why
would Disney uh go ahead I think you
know the answer to that question but he
had that card he doesn't realize that it
was embarrassing he had that card of him
pitching on the the mound laminated and
it's on his desk made into a tops card
made into it yeah yeah he came closer to
hitting first base than home plate with
that pitch Leah Thomas
would have thrown a better breaking
balls
excuse me is that her name yeah I think
so I think it's Leah Thomas yeah Stephen
Hawking Stephen Hawking could literally
just accelerate his yeah yeah
he had good junk yes yes he did Stephen
his fingers were perfect for the
hard stuff on the corner good I used to
use him uh to I put his hand in a
vending machine to pick up the stuff man
stop doing this this is the Basin that's
my hand be breaking ball oh
this is what happens when you know too
much
he's doing donuts on the pitcher's mouth
the whole crowds go throw that thing
also as long as he's doing the donuts
well fauci's on the pitcher's man that
would be great wouldn't it hit and run
it's an Underdog Story you just stop
rooting for because your team can't win
yeah
I have eight minutes on Stephen Hawk and
I'm still not giving enough I know
absolutely not but it's so damn funny
that's a reason to without you in the
picture just run over by Sammy Davis Jr
in a Cadillac
get that one back all right uh seven
plus one things fauci is most likely to
do next number four Gerald Cruella
Deville but with beagles yes he'd be a
good one yeah make a coach go doesn't
make a coat out of it well after they
get eaten some of us want things how she
is most likely to do next uh number
three homelessness
[Laughter]
I think he yeah that's perfect yeah and
uh number two he said you know things he
would most like to do next uh finally uh
finally get around to creating his
laboratory Institute for engineering
more severe forms of AIDS
ah more transmissible well you know he's
put on the back burner it's a passion
project yeah there's only so much time
and uh I actually have the seven plus
one because Nick actually you were
foreshadowing it uh earlier uh seven
plus one thinks fauci is most likely to
do next what's number one what he'd
really like to do is direct yes he would
he would like to director and the plus
one of course is a b named trivago's
next Garden known this has been this
week seven plus one
[Music]
the chamber
Nick depaolo of course uh he's at uh
hyenas in Dallas this Friday and then
Saturday Fort Worth for just uh
finishing that again go see separate
cities funniest stand-up working in the
country I'm pretty fortunate I've got
the fastest man on his feet here Dave
Landau and uh you know funniest stand up
I think that uh another senseless
killing the EP Nick is possibly the
funniest comedy album that's my favorite
of uh all the tremendous work I've put
out
um they're all great but that is
probably my favorite Comedy album of all
time and I shot it in a club actually
and not a theater but um yes I jammed
more into that album that's what I used
to care about stand up um oh stop it
it'll never go away I was born that way
uh but no that was uh my favorite too
Stephen yeah it's a it's a it's a lot of
fun guys you can listen to that too I
think it's on it's on Spotify it's on
Pandora it's on all those places where
people can and the uh the guy the cop
that's on the cover holding the police
tape that was an actual uh Minneapolis
cop who was shot it was in the national
news oh really ambushed yes and um had
like 30 something up operations on his
arm him and that was two Minneapolis
cops uh holding the one he had retired
after he got wait on another census
killing someone with a pizza on it isn't
it
Pizza yeah another senseless killing the
EP isn't there a pizza in the cupboard
what kind of stereotypical I'll bring it
up for you afterwards on Spotify there's
a pizza
yeah no it's uh
it's no it's this is the dog father I'm
sorry I'm not sure
what you're thinking no it was uh it was
a bar stool with blood all over it and
uh
remember the no I don't clearly so
crisis all right okay we get it cop good
he backs the blue we get it
who would have thought a whop from
Boston would back the blue
come on did I trigger him no are you uh
you're from Massachusetts but you live
in Georgia now I do I live in Savannah
Georgia I should have moved there 20
years ago absolutely love it I can't
imagine living on the Eastern Seaboard
right now why is that some places uh
it's terrible
why not Georgia well are you trying to
you I see what you're saying he's trying
to lure me into what's wrong with her
it's a you know a politics uh awful you
know crime homelessness not in Savannah
no I said in the Eastern Seaboard well
what's that on there well technically
that goes all the way down to Florida
exactly Northeastern okay the
northeastern Seaboard for crying out
loud I don't need smokes I have Nick
depalo here I think New York
specifically like a drunk girl let's see
what are you talking about uh Myrtle
Beach talking about South Carolina what
the [ __ ]
here we go you better do some voices for
me
right here great friend of mine from the
Seaboard air said Sullivan yes anyways
for you people in your late 90s go to
bed really big guinea um
a really big grease ball right here
playing hyenas
I love it when Rich little lady does a
Reagan
so uh
it's timely you can see him in Vegas
I'm performing in Vegas yes I was for
Sean Hannity's Freedom tour yeah
favorites they're like no no no we're
gonna do a rich little instead I said oh
okay I'm gonna go swallow a knife right
now yeah thanks
I'm gonna call Fred travalina to solve
my
traveling Rich Richard Lewis has the
best
joke of the Fred travalina referencing
oh is that the one I think I know but I
think I probably told you last time I
was here because it's the uh box yes yes
he's doing a bit about you ever hit you
know what I'm talking about yeah yeah
but I'm not gonna do it good all right
we'll do it on my club it's chat
Thursday
mug Club whatever that is yeah we'll
have some oh yeah okay
good show all right come in come in here
you know he's a guest we plug a show at
hyenas no I don't I don't honestly yeah
I know I don't know I see I don't know
what it is I know you can join up and
get a mug right yeah well it's kind of
spot off boy you get baked ziti in
something
what was the name your last album garlic
sun-dried tomatoes
good photos you want to trigger him you
know what you just do you just uh
reference that scene in a True Romance
and uh you know because he's Sicilian
just tell him that you know there's
someone else I'm half seal and half a
tank
he's been kissed by a rose a son of a
[ __ ] right here
and burned in a fire pit a ball on the
nose
[Laughter]
you know I'm more Irish
Irish Scottish than I am Italian really
I just found that out from uh you know
what 23. me yeah did your whole life you
think you were just all Italian I
thought I was no not all Italian yeah
you know my mother's uh
Scottish and a little English and yeah
so a drunk but there's some Irish back
yep
no very boring church church going and
uh okay oh there we go but uh yeah I I'm
actually like one percent more I've I'm
more sub-Saharan African than Elizabeth
Warren is Native American so he took it
from the waist down yes listen what's
his height what that's you know Southern
Italian there's a you know there's a
more hiding in your wood pile somewhere
yeah that's what I said to Patrice
O'Neal
thanks to you great great great
grandparents I have some of your blood
me
Savages yeah
okay go watch that scene in True Romance
my boxing coach if everyone would
mentioned he'd be like he would just
start turning it up on me and tuning me
he did not like when I made that joke
about Sicilians they have a whole thing
about that no more I think it has to do
with being you know conquered okay so
the Ukraine refugee
crisis
just trying to think of a way out here I
feel like Sammy Davis looking at the
horn ornament and it's just about to go
through my eye no matter what you're
about to smash your head so let me set
this up here because and I know this
will get Nick and everyone worked up but
this is something that really is
pervasive it's obviously meant to be
uh it's it's meant to be uh
I don't know what it's meant to be I
will say this in action it's evil in
practice it's evil right now they are
trying to present the refugee situation
with Ukraine let's just get rid of where
you line up with Ukraine and Russia for
a second let's get rid of that there are
refugees okay there are women and
children who need to go someplace okay
let's just start with that now what is
the left trying to do they're trying to
say that well actually the only reason
that people now care about these women
and children the refugees in other words
if you have empathy if you have a heart
they want you to feel guilty in this
case why because something something
refugees
racism it's because they're white don't
take my word for it a lot of people on
TV
didn't expect a war like this to happen
in let's say certain neighborhoods now
people are going to be like oh to see
this in in Europe to see this
like I'll tell you not I don't know
about you but I was shocked to see how
many reporters around the world by the
way seem to think that it's more of a
tragedy when white people have to flee
their countries because I guess what the
donkeys were built for it okay let's
face it the world is paying attention
because this is happening in Europe if
this was happening anywhere else would
we see the same outpouring of support
and compassion but we don't need to ask
ourselves if the international response
would be the same if Russia Unleashed
their horror on a country that wasn't
white and largely Christian I don't know
the illin Omar clip too
can someone get that to me Elon Omar it
was it was in the Montage yeah yeah uh
so Elan Omar also said that this is
something we need to do because let me
know when you guys get that the one who
made love to her brother yeah yeah she
needs to go to remedial not bang your
brother 101. maybe it's a night school
yeah I don't know maybe we have more
sympathy because they don't bang their
brothers you would think so but that's
just that's your privilege talking so
this is echoed by the media of course
and not just these folks who you just
heard in the late night with Joyce Joy
Reid what does she I guess she's media
almost former media but here we have
from ABC let's read some headlines
Europe's unified welcome of Ukrainian
refugees exposes double standard for
non-white Asylum Seekers daily beasts
their headline reads refugees uh from
other Wars want to know why white
ukrainians get VIP treatment and my
favorite from the guardian Europe has
rediscovered compassion for refugees but
only if they're white I thought that
[ __ ] was why that's what they want you
to think it is
still my favorite quote
a great quote
um passionate here's the thing
it's 100 incorrect it's incorrect by the
numbers and it's incorrect In sentiment
let me just give you the numbers pretty
quickly okay uh 2016 by 2016 Europe took
in 5.2 million refugees from Syria Iraq
and Afghanistan okay as of December 2021
America the United States of America
took in uh 65 000 Afghan refugees and uh
the United States had overseas bases I
need to make sure that I say that
otherwise people you know uh and uh
Biden raised the refugee cap to 125 000
in light of the Afghanistan crisis
largely created by Him now those are you
know white Christian places that we yeah
well less than one percent were
Christian under Obama despite the fact
that these refugees leaving from places
like Syria right Iraq uh Christians were
burned in cages yeah yeah you're kind of
surprised like well why is it less than
one percent of you coming here are the
people who are being burned in cages but
you're part of the demographic that
burns them in cages they're looking for
a new place to do burnings yes exactly
higher necklaces yes have you considered
the Wicker man hmm
Albuquerque's nice so it won't bring
back your honey so let's go to uh
Ukrainian refugees most of them have
gone to Poland okay Poland Slovakia
Hungary Romania neighboring countries to
be clear and that's kind of the rule
with refugees right the international
rules state that you're supposed to at
least a sentiment I don't know if it's
an Unwritten rule no but it's a written
rule you're supposed to go to the
nearest neighboring country if you're a
fleeing persecution to be safe now that
doesn't mean that if you're just coming
from South America from a country that
is not as good as the United States of
America you get to come here in a Dodge
Caravan and claim Refugee status right
and you don't get to come here just
because the economy is not doing well in
your country right that's not Refugee so
65 000 5.2 million in Europe uh anyone
want to guess how many uh
how many Ukrainian refugees had
resettled here in the United States Nick
do you want to take a wild guess
um 46. yep close that must be a lot
because being called racist for taking
that's 40 more it was seven ah it was
seven oh and now they plan to admit up
to a hundred thousand ukrainians
bringing that total to a hundred
thousand and seven
I was pretty close you were close I was
being a wise ass and listen to a thing
you guys have said for the last five
minutes
46. appreciate it you still thinking I
love that you went for the comical
number and we're 40 higher that's
exactly we're 40 higher and a hundred
thousand lower than the the aspirations
I blocked it out right after you
mentioned the premise of that of them
accusing us of being I I go I go yeah I
go ballistic I go ballistic there's a
bread it's like a fire in your brain it
is I have to just back off and go I
don't want to get well I appreciate that
you didn't back over that too if people
want to go see a stand-up he pulls no
punches and I will say this a lot of
comedians these days have turned into
[ __ ] boys so I do appreciate that about
Nick
um and I get mad too look it's one of
those things rape is terrible of course
rape is one of the worst crimes you can
possibly commit some can argue worse
than murder people have argued that says
who it's also well okay you doing the
splits out in front of Delta Kappa
fraternity eight times a week yes
streaming now I'm super drunk I hope no
one takes advantage of me you're fine
not interested not necessarily the same
but rapists were about accusing someone
of rape falsely knowingly like Brett
Kavanaugh that's horrible right racism
is absolutely terrible we can all agree
falsely accusing someone of racism is
absolutely horrible and it's what they
do to try and Destroy someone's life of
course people are infuriated now here's
something let me just presuppose this
maybe the reason that public sentiment
uh Americans find themselves more
sympathetic more uh I you know I don't
even know where they get this from I
honestly have no idea I didn't even know
that Americans were more sympathetic to
Ukrainian refugees until the media said
that that was the case and it's because
we're racist honestly I know that most
Americans were pretty sympathetic to
refugees across the board whether they
believe that we should resettle them or
not but let me free Escape
how did they even Escape or were they
just already here and we were like you
might not want to go back there's seven
right
yeah it seems almost there just one
Lifeboat yeah how did they get here
that's like seven ukrainians were
visiting and tried to take back a vape
pen for their WNBA playoffs no sense
like they were probably here and they
were like oh you can't go back there
they've taken over your country they're
running yeah that's like we're not even
accepting them they were just seven just
seven they were just at their aunt's
house but maybe the reason that
Americans might feel more sympathetic is
because these are I don't know women and
children right these are women and
children leaving Ukraine because
contrary to what happened in the Middle
East and by the way there have been
refugees from the Middle East
always since forever they've never found
peace there there's never been the case
since any of you watching right now have
been alive no one wants to take in a
bunch of refugees from the Middle East
who left the women and children to be
tortured and killed right that was the
problem that we faced with some of these
refugees before and according to Pure
research less than one percent of the
Syrian refugees were Christian under
Obama according to Pew research all
references available at lottery.com
despite again Christians being the ones
who are primarily persecuted in those
countries now in the Ukraine in Ukraine
sorry not the Ukraine in Ukraine
refugees are women and children since
silinsky banned men aged 18 to 60 from
leaving the country which by the way is
also a sign that you have a really good
country yeah yeah fantastic country if
you're willing to run out but listen
build walls to keep them in yeah yeah
you have to stay in fight what does that
mean just go stand in the way of them
yes make sure no but they're they
understand Russia Russia is just going
to do what he did to grozny he's just
gonna bomb the hell out of it until it
is absolutely the worst destroyed City
on the planet and then he's going to
move to the next city and he's going to
do it again he's doing in Miracle right
now if you look at some of the pictures
that you see and I don't know if I'm
pronouncing it correctly it is it is
like the Moon it is like another planet
it doesn't look like a city inhabited by
human beings we moved on from big girls
yes we did when people are fleeing that
you have compassion the men are staying
the women are coming from that right
right they're fighting another country
invading they're not fighting a faction
within their country right like in Syria
and other countries in the Middle East
right I'm sorry only the left in this
country well women and children being
slaughtered can find race that's their
focus racism exactly this country was
built on inviting people from all over
the planet wasn't it I mean think about
it we even let the Irish in exactly yeah
big mistake buyers are worse there
exactly
keep your keep your famines overseas
also I don't know if you know this I
don't know if you know a country that
has a little bit of a racism problem
sometimes the Ukraine wow oh yeah do
they really yeah Ukraine has some they
have some problems with some people who
are I don't know if you know they're
very white
foreign
they don't like Russians yeah that's
what I hear too yeah that's it's a beef
that's there did we get did you guys get
the Elon Omar clip guys we got it okay
good so this is also of course uh uh
everyone's favorite uh brother merrier
slash Banger and Snopes doesn't know for
sure they haven't verified it so uh I
don't know how about you do your job and
verify it Snopes
just carry the one
here's Elon Omar uh talking about
something other than relations with her
uh biological brother as we talk about
this crisis uh in in Ukraine uh we have
to make sure that there is a a reckoning
I hope this is a learning moment for all
of us because obviously there's a a
difference in the way they talk about
Ukrainian refugees who are white on the
way black and brown and Muslim refugees
from elsewhere
um are are talked about yeah how did you
get here and become a representative
exactly what a nitwit and who's they by
the way right yeah
Gucci married to a white guy yeah her
brother right
it says that's her second marriage yeah
to the white guy Pretty Fly though so
honey put your silly hat on and go
pretend you care for yes please do
thanksgiving's like a meat marketer yeah
would you pass the creamer no
I love the pictures that they were
showing by the way when she was talking
women children old men that's it right
and then they showed the dog that they
show the dog the dog killed it or having
to roam the streets in her Homeland you
need to train that dog to go kill them
it just sucks that that's the narrative
though when it's certain people and you
have all these different people working
together to push this on everyone right
it's all about racism it's right seven
people in this country hey how about
this how about we don't take Ukrainian
refugees uh either how about that how
about none across the board yeah yeah is
that fair does that make does that make
me a prick how about none across the
board white brown whatever okay fend for
yourself go to the nearest nearest
bordering country yeah uh not across the
ocean
sounds good by the way if you're Pro
taking in tons of refugees and spending
other people's money and putting them in
other communities and not your take one
first yeah go ahead lead by example you
got plenty of room Nancy I know you have
plenty of rooms in your house you got
plenty of ice cream we know that for
sure take some people into your house do
it you could start in San Francisco the
city that you've turned into a hell hole
yeah do that there by the way I don't
even care you know put it in a townhouse
have them live under the stairs like
Harry Potter for all like here just keep
some skin in the game let's go you'd
bring them over from maripule and then
look at San Francisco I'm not standing
you in this city you use it's like a
biological weapon they just come in and
see all the pills they're like this is
so insane
leaving Somalia yeah
first I'll go back screamers all right
so look this is one of those issues
where I just think you guys can comment
below and it depends where you line up
uh refugees or no refugees and you know
what if there are a few people out there
who you know the few remaining the four
remaining actual white supremacists you
know if you guys think we should only
have white refugees and uh let people
know uh who to not like in the comments
section
just hold Let your freak flag fly but uh
Nick de Paul is going to be in Fort
Worth on Saturday right Dallas on Friday
hyenas we're going to go to chat and of
course the huge we'll change my mind
coming Monday and Tuesday what's uh
what's happening
oh
son of a [ __ ]
good